AND NOW IT IS TIME FOR TONIGHT'S
#HASHTAGWARS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
THE ACADEMY AWARDS ARE ON SUNDAY
AND THAT MEANS TWO THINGS: OSCAR
PARTIES AND HANGOVERS ON MONDAY.
SO TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS
#DRUNKFILMS.
EXAMPLES WOULD BE CAPTAIN MORGAN
PHILLIPS, LAST OF THE MOJITOS,
OR MILLER'S GENUINE DRAFT
CROSSING.
(LAUGHTER)
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK, AND GO!
ANDY.
>> WHISKY DICK TRACY.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: I CAN'T GET A BONER
RIGHT NOW.
POINTS.
NATASHA.
>> D.U.I. HEART HUCKABEES.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
CORDDRY.
>> IT'S A MADD, MADD, MADD,
MOTHERS AGAINST DRUNK DRIVING.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS, POINTS.
WELL DONE.
ANDY.
>> SCHINDLER'S WINE LIST.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
NATASHA.
>> THE GOOD, THE BAD AND THE
UGLY AND I (BLEEP) ALL THREE.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS!
POINTS.
ANDY.
>> KEG STAND BY ME.
>> Chris: YES, POINTS.
ANDY DALY.
>> A CLOCKWORK ORANGE JUICE AND
VODKA ALSO KNOWN AS A CLOCKWORK
SCREWDRIVER.
>> Chris: YES, CLOCKWORK
SCREWDRIVER, WELL PLAYED.
YES, POINTS.
ROB CORDDRY.
>> THE UNBEARABLE LIGHTNESS OF
MILLER LIGHT.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: YES, I WILL GIVE YOU
THAT.
ANDY.
>> 12-YEAR-OLD SCOTCH A SLAVE.
(AUDIENCE REACTS)
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: LISTEN, AUDIENCE OF
WHITE PEOPLE, CALM DOWN.
(LAUGHTER)
NO RACIAL BOUNDARIES HAVE BEEN
VIOLATED IN THE PREVIOUS JOKE.
IT IS OKAY.
POINTS TO ANDY DALY.
>> THAT WAS IN GOOD TASTE.
>> I AM LEGEND AND I AM AN
ALCOHOLIC.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS, WELL DONE,
ROB CORDDRY.